avec neuf joueuses arrivé à
l'intersaison le club de football de
montigny qui évolue en division 2 est en
pleine reconstruction peu d'expérience
et un groupe très jeune n'empêche pas
lésiné monteyne ans maillot vert de
réaliser une très bonne entame de match
face à templemars vendeville
le club yvelinois ouvre le score à la
demi-heure de jeu par l'intermédiaire de
leur capitaine margot robin qui ajuste
la gardienne une petite balle piquée
dans le petit filet mais sur un superbe
coup franc aux 20 mètres et contre le
cours du jeu
templemars vendeville égalise
en seconde période la maîtrise
collective et toujours yvelinoise mêlée
josine montay ne se procure pas de
réelle occasion sur un mauvais
alignement défensif
la gardienne unis montaigne ne peut rien
faire sur ce lob astucieux une erreur de
jeunesse à ce niveau évoluant très bas
la muraille rouge de templemars qui mais
ne rompt pas face aux derniers assauts
ennemis montain l'efficacité c'est aussi
ça l'apprentissage du haut niveau